donald trump se apresura para conquistar
el voto latino y su siguiente parada es
florida tram ha registrado un recurrente
discurso antiinmigrante especialmente
contra los mexicanos y centroamericanos
que buscan establecerse en eeuu pero hay
un sector de la población latina que se
inclinan por el mandatario además de los
conservadores están aquellos que han
visto fracasar sus países de origen en
manos de gobiernos de izquierda como
cuba y venezuela
trump ha advertido sin pruebas que si
los demócratas llegan a la casa blanca
eeuu podría sufrir las crisis que
atraviesan estos países
no podemos permitir que nuestro país se
convierta en una nación socialista
para generar rechazo hacia joe biden
trump lo ha acusado de ser un aliado del
castro-chavismo pese a que el candidato
demócrata ha condenado al presidente
venezolano nicolás maduro ambos reclaman
ser la mejor opción para los hispanos
ayer se le ha fallado a la comunidad
hispana una y otra vez y eso no es un
secreto después de california y texas
florida es el estado con el mayor número
de votantes latinos pero a diferencia de
estos dos primeros que son demócrata y
republicano respectiva
este es considerado un swing states o
estado pendular es decir que no siempre
se inclina por el mismo partido
florida además es clave en la carrera
por la casa blanca aporta 29 electores
de los 270 necesarios para ganar la
presidencia por lo que convencer a sus
votantes es necesario para asegurar la
victoria